My husband has a weird obsession with Takis
and can't go longer than a week without having them.
When he opened his bag of Takis today,
he realized that they all went stale,
so I just decided to make him some.
I combined some corn flour with some water,
salt, and some sugar
before kneading it and letting it hydrate
while I made my spice mixture.
I combined habanero powder with cayenne pepper,
paprika, citric acid,
some red beat coloring to give it that really red color
before setting that aside
and providing my dough into dime sized pieces
and rolling them into little balls.
Since they were all rolled out,
I made sure to cover them with a damp towel while I worked on
one piece at a time. Put my dough in between some plastic
before pressing it flat and rolling it into that signature taki shape.
And I kept repeating this process
with all of my little pieces of dough.
I then transferred them over to a plate while my oil was heating up.
I made sure it reached 350 degrees
before putting all of my chips in there
and letting them get lightly more brown than I usually would.
Toss them in my spice mixture and then they were done.
These takis are Lucky's favorite snack.
He was so excited to try them
and he was so shocked at how much they tasted like the actual thing.
And that plate was gone in under five minutes.